Київ у листопаді -
наразі останній притулок на довгому і небезпечному шляху
сирійця Яхья Салібі і його дружини-українки Марії.
Родина, типова для глобалізованого світу:
познайомилися у Китаї, хотіли переїхати жити в Дамаск.
"У нас була ідея повернутися жити до Сирії,
це було в 2010-му- 2011-му роках.
Ніхто і не думав, що там почнеться.
Так само, як і Україна - Сирія була абсолютно безпечною країною."
Після того, як почалася війна у Cирії,
подружжя переїхало до будинку Марії
Східній Україні. Місце, яке Яхья
бачив лише на фотографіях.
Вони одружилися у вересні 2013-го.
На весіллі не було жодного члена родини нареченого.
Доля розкидала їх по світу.
Життя почало налагоджуватися. З допомогою батьків Марії
молодята відкрили крамничку з продажу інструментів.
днак через кілька місяців і Східну Україну охопила війна.
"Коли вони підняли російський прапор, я вже зрозумів,
що відбудуться великі зміни."
Однак вони не могли просто все кинути
і залишити місто. Марія чекала першу дитину - дівчинку Єву.
"Ми поїхали до лікарні на околиці міста.
Ми були виснажені, чутно було стрілянину та вибухи.
Один стрес за іншим."
"Одного разу я потрапив прямо під перестрілку.
Моя дружина зателефонувала і сказала -
негайно повертайся додому. Я повернувся,
а під будинком лежали тіла загиблих.
Я мусив їх переступити, аби зайти до будинку."
Через місяць після народження дОньки, вони вирішили кинути все
і переїхати до Києва. Подорож була небезпечною.
"Ми під"їхали до мосту - у нас є фотографія.
Ми їхали на високій швидкості і в останній момент
з'ясували, що міст зруйнований."
Однак їхні проблеми не закінчилися після прибуття до Києва.
хья і його родина не мали ані даху над головою, ані роботи.
Роботодавці не хотіли зв’язуватися з переселенцями
через бюрократичну тяганину.
Яхья - досвідчений проект-менеджер, отримав
пропозицію на роботу з-за кордону.
Однак його статус - допзахист -
надає йому в Україні вкрай обмежені права.
А щоб отримати українське громадянство через шлюб,
йому потрібно виїхати з країни і подати документи
на возз'єднання сім'ї з-за кордону.
Утім, його сирійський паспорт
більше не дійсний і виїхати він не може.
Тож почати бізнес було єдиним можливим варіантом.
Озброївшись кавовою машиною,
Яхья з кількома іншими сирійцями зміг відкрити невеличку кав’ярню.
"Це важко, треба рухатися.
Потрібно мати 2-3 роботи, щоб вижити.
Я втратив свою батьківщину і моя дружина також.
Вона у Києві, однак почувається тут як іноземка.
Чи зміниться життя цієї родини, залежатиме від того,
чи зможуть вони пройти через усі перипетії української бюрократії,
аби Яхья таки отримав українське громадянство.
Це відкрило б їм шлях до нового життя.